imagine thinking that so-called free  school lunch is the problem and not the  financially  and not the fact that huge corporations  sometimes pay zero taxes despite  profiting handsomely handsomely uh just  such a backwards world and the dis day  the indignant Martha McCallum can you  imagine God help she says God help kids  who think they grow up thinking that  school lunches is free this is a huge  part of the problem ideologically in  this country where we end up having to  put energy and time into these debates  when we could all just agree like hey  school lunch being prepaid through  property taxes it's no big deal let's  focus on something better let's improve  education uh and by the way if you're  hungry at school you're not going to  learn you're not going to learn so  there's a number of different ways in  this in which this just makes absolutely  perfect sense